Smarty pants, egg head, brainiac.
You've heard terms like these before, maybe
you've even been on the receiving end of one
of them.
But actually, defining intelligence is a lot
trickier than just coming up with new names
for smart people.
I mean, intelligence isn't like height or
weight; you can't just toss them on a scale
and give it an exact measurement.
It has different meanings for different cultures
and ages and skill sets.
So what is intelligence?
It's a question that doesn't give us a lot
of answers, but it does open a bunch of other
equally important and interesting questions.
Like, what influences it?
And how can it be assessed?
Is it a single, general ability, or does it
cover a range of aptitudes and skills and
talents?
How do things like creativity and innovation
factor in?
Or genetics or environment, or education?
And what about emotional intelligence?
Most agree that it's best to think of intelligence
not of a concrete thing so much as a concept,
the ability to learn from experience, solve
problems, and use knowledge to adapt to new
experiences.
We've often used intelligence tests, to assess
and compare mental aptitude, but these tests
have a long, complex and dark history.
I mean there are Nazis involved so, yeah.
So as you'll see, there are reasons that intelligence
is one of the most hotly debated subjects
in psychology.
It's complicated and controversial.
[Intro]
What if I'm the world's greatest Rubik's cube
solver but a terrible speller?
Or a truly gifted artist who's barely mastered
long division?
Could anyone say I was intelligent or not
based on those different aptitudes, or would
it be more accurate to measure my brainpower
on several different scales?
Around the turn of the twentieth century,
British psychologist Charles Spearman suggested
that yes, we do have one comprehensive general
intelligence that underlies all of specific
mental abilities.
He called it the G-Factor.
Spearman conceded that while people may have
special talents like basket weaving or saxophone
solos or doing crossword puzzles, those things
still fell under "G".
And he helped develop a statistical procedure
called factor analysis to try to determine
how certain clusters of skills might correlate
with another one.
Like, say someone who tests well in spatial
skills might be good with numbers.
We might then refer to that cluster of skills,
that factor, as spatial-numeric reasoning.
But to Spearman, the G-factor was something
of an uber-factor connected to all intelligent
behavior from architecture to healing to survival
skills, and it's why people who do well on
one kind of cognitive test tend to do well
on others.
But as you can imagine, reducing intelligence
to a single numerical test score was and is
problematic.
L.L. Thurstone, an American pioneer of psychometrics
and one of Spearman's first challengers, was
not into ranking people on a single scale.
Thurstone administered 56 different tests
to his subjects then used them to identify
seven clusters of mental abilities.
By this system, you might turn out to be great
at like verbal comprehension but less stellar
at something like numerical ability.
Sounds fair.
But when researchers followed up on his findings,
they actually did see that high scores in
one aptitude usually meant good scores in
the others, essentially backing up some evidence
for some kind of G-factor.
Even though their ideas did not often align,
Spearman and Thurstone together paved the
way for more contemporary theories on intelligence.
For example, American psychologist Howard
Gardner views intelligence as multiple abilities
that come in different forms.
He references instances of brain damage where
one ability may be destroyed while others
stay perfectly intact.
Savants usually have some limited metal abilities
but one exceptional ability when it comes
to like, computing figures or memorizing the
complete works of Shakespeare.
To Gardner, this suggests that we have multiple
intelligences beyond the G-factor.
In fact, he believes that we have eight intelligences,
ranging from our skills with numbers and words
to our ability to understand physical space
and the natural world.
American psychologist Robert Sternberg tends
to agree with Gardner, though he boils them
down into three intelligences: analytical,
or problem-solving intelligence, creative
intelligence, or the ability to adapt to new
situations, and practical intelligence for
everyday tasks.
Both of these models seem reasonable, too,
and Gardner and Sternberg's work has helped
teachers appreciate students' variety of talents.
But research has suggested that even these
different ways to be smart are also linked
by some underlying general intelligence factor.
So what about other less tangible forms of
intelligence, like creativity, our ability
to produce ideas that are both novel and valuable?
How can a test that demands one correct answer
account for more creative solutions, so-called
"divergent thinking".
Well, traditional intelligence tests can't,
and so far, while we do have some tests that
look at creative potential, we don't have
a standardized system for quantifying creativity.
But Sternberg and his colleagues have identified
five main components of creativity, which
are useful for framing our understanding of
what creative intelligence is and how it works.
If you go through the list, you know who I
think is really great at almost all of them?
Sherlock Holmes.
Hear me out.
First we've got expertise, or a well-developed
base of knowledge.
This just means knowing a lot about a lot.
Whether it's arcane poisons, jellyfish behavior,
or how to recognize a secret passage behind
a book shelf, expertise provides the mind
with all sorts of data to work with and combine
in new ways.
Obviously Sherlock has incredible imaginative
thinking skills, too, which provide him with
the ability to see things in new ways, recognize
patterns and make connections.
He loves nothing more than rehashing these
breadcrumb trails for the dopey constables
at the end of the case.
Sternberg also thought a venturesome personality
contributes to creativity.
By hanging around opium dens and chasing thugs
and generally courting danger, Sherlock routinely
seeks new experiences, tolerates risk, and
perseveres in overcoming obstacles.
And everyone knows he's driven by intrinsic
motivation.
I mean, he wants to help the widow discover
the thief and everything, but really, Sherlock
is driven by his own interest and sense of
challenge.
He gets pleasure from the work itself.
And finally, Sherlock benefits from a creative
environment which sparks, supports, and refines
his ideas.
For so affectionately maintaining this environment
on Sherlock's behalf, we largely have Dr.
Watson to thank.
Sherlock was obviously an academic and creative
genius, but he was pretty weak in another
form of intelligence: the emotional kind.
Emotional intelligence, defined in 1997 by
psychologist Peter Salovey and John Mayer
-- no, not, not that one-- is the ability
to perceive, understand, manage, and use emotions.
I don't know about you, but I know plenty
of smart people who have a hard time processing
social information.
The most brilliant mathematician may struggle
to communicate with colleagues, neighbors,
or staff at the local deli.
Likewise, Sherlock often annoys, offends,
or even baffles those around him.
Perceiving emotions means being able to recognize
them in faces, and even in music, film, and
stories.
Understanding emotions relates to being able
to predict them and how they might change.
And managing emotions comes down to knowing
how to appropriately express yourself in various
situations.
And finally, emotional intelligence also means
using emotions to enable adaptive or creative
thinking; like knowing how to manage conflict
or comfort a grieving friend or work well
with others.
Much like creative intelligence, emotional
intelligence can be measured to some degree
through testing, but there's no standardized
way to, like, assign a numerical value.
So if we can't perfectly quantify things like
creativity or emotional smarts, how did we
come up with a way to measure intelligence?
Well, as I mentioned earlier, it's a sordid
story.
The first attempts to do it in the western
world began with English scientist Francis
Galton in the 1800s.
Taking a page from his famous cousin Charles
Darwin's theories on natural selection, Galton
wondered how that premise might extend to
humans' natural ability when it came to intelligence.
He suggested that our smarts have a lot to
do with heredity, so if we encouraged smart
people to breed with each other, we could
essentially create a master race of geniuses.
If that sounds a little sketchy, it's because
it was, like, really, really sketchy!!
This study of how to selectively and supposedly
improve the human population, especially by
encouraging breeding in some people and discouraging
it in others, is called "eugenics".
A term Galton himself coined, and I'll get
back to, in a minute.
But around the turn of the twentieth century
when eugenics was taking off, the French government
mandated that all children must attend school.
Many of these kids had never been in a classroom
and teachers wanted to figure out how they
could identify kids who needed extra help.
Enter Alfred Binet and Theodore Simon, two
French psychologists who were commissioned
to develop a test to measure a child's so-called
mental age.
The concept of a kid's mental age is essentially
the level of performance associated with a
certain chronological age.
So if six year old Bruno tests as well as
the average six year old, he'd have a mental
age of six.
Binet believed that his tests could measure
a child's current mental abilities, but that
intelligence wasn't a fixed, inborn thing.
He believed a person's capabilities could
be raised with proper attention, self-discipline
and practice.
In other words, he was no eugenicist.
He was hoping that his tests would improve
children's education by identifying those
who needed extra attention.
But Binet also feared that these tests would,
in the wrong hands, be used to do just the
opposite: labeling children as "lost causes",
limiting their opportunities.
And wow, was he on to something because that
is pretty much exactly what happened.
German psychologist William Stern used revisions
of Binet and Simon's work to create the famous
intelligence quotient, or IQ measurement.
At the time, your IQ was simply your mental
age, divided by your chronological age, multiplied
by a hundred.
So for example Bruno is six, and so is his
mental age, so his IQ ranks at a hundred,
but his little sister Betty is a four year-old
with a mental age of five, so her IQ would
be 125.
That formula works pretty well for measuring
kids, but it falls apart when it comes to
adults who don't hit measurable developmental
steps like kids do.
I mean there's no real difference between
a mental age of 34 and 35.
But Stanford professor Lewis Terman started
promoting the widespread use of intelligence
tests in the early 1900s, and with his help
the US government began the world's first
massive ministration of intelligence tests,
when it assessed World War I army recruits
and immigrants fresh off the boat.
Unlike Binet, Terman did use these numerical
findings as a kind of label, and he thought
his tests could, as he put it: "ultimately
result in curtailing the reproduction of feeble-mindedness".
This kind of testing played right into eugenicists'
sensibilities, and soon the eugenics movement
in the US had a pretty good fanclub, raising
money from the Carnegie's and Rockafeller's
and with proponents working at Harvard and
Columbia and Cornell.
In the first half of the 21st century, intelligence
tests were used to enforce the sterilization
of about 60,000 people, around a third of
whom were in California.
Most were poor white women, often unwed mothers
or prostitutes.
Other eugenics efforts persisted later into
the century, and there is evidence of poor
African American, Native American, or Latina
women being forcibly or covertly sterilized
in large numbers as recently as the 1970s.
But do you know who really loved their eugenics?
The Nazis.
Hitler and his cronies took the idea of intelligence
testing to even darker conclusions.
The Nazis were all about selecting against
so-called "feeble-mindedness" and other undesirable
traits as they sought to strengthen what they
saw as their Aryan nation.
They sterilized or simply executed hundreds
of thousands of victims based of their answers
to IQ test questions that were really more
abut adhering to social norms than measuring
actual intelligence.
Questions like: "Who was Bismarck?" and "What
does Christmas signify?"
So you can see how this terrifying history
still makes some people leery of how such
tests are administered, interpreted, and weighted.
Today we understand that intelligence, as
defined by all the people we've talked about
here, does appear to be a real and measurable
phenomenon.
But no one can say that they've disentangled
all of the would-be genetic, environmental,
educational, and socio-economic components
of it.
In the end, it's best to think of intelligence
as something about which we've still got a
lot to learn.
And next week, we'll talk about how we test
intelligence today and the problems we still
face in doing it.
Today, your intelligent mind learned about
the history of how we think about and define
different types of intelligence, what the
G-factor is, and how Sherlock Holmes is incredibly
intelligent but emotionally unintelligent.
You also learned about the history and methods
of intelligence testing, IQ scores, and how
eugenics turned to the dark side, and has
since made even talking about intelligence
kind of controversial.
Thank you for watching, especially fto our
Subbable subscribers who make Crash Course
possible.
To find out how you can become a supporter,
just go to Subbable.com/crashcourse.
This episode was written by Kathleen Yale,
edited by Blake de Pastino, and our consultant
is Dr. Ranjit Bhagwat.
Our director and editor is Nicholas Jenkins,
the script supervisor is Michael Aranda, who
is also our sound designer, and the graphics
team is Thought Cafe.